MOVE SAYING HE DID NOT KNOW THAT
PAUL MANAFORT WAS HEAD OF THE
MOB AND ASKED WHAT ABOUT COMEY
AND CLINTON AND ALL THE OTHERS.
PRESIDENT TRUMP SAID IT
KIM JONG UN IS ALWAYS JUST A
PHONE CALL AWAY.
THE PRESIDENT TALKING MORE ABOUT
HIS SUMMIT WITH THE NORTH KOREAN
LEADER.
>> I HAVE A GOOD RELATIONSHIP
WITH KIM JONG UN.
THAT'S A VERY IMPORTANT THING.
I CAN NOW SAY, WE HAVE A
PROBLEM.
I TOLD HIM.
I GAVE HIM A VERY DIRECT NUMBER.
HE CAN NOW CALL ME IF HE HAS
DIFFICULTY.
OR I CAN CALL HIM.
WE HAVE COMMUNICATION.
>> BACK HOME AFTER THE SINGAPORE
SUMMIT, PRESIDENT TRUMP IS
TAKING A VICTORY LAP,
HIGHLIGHTING THE NEGOTIATION
AND, PEOPLE ARE SHOCKED THAT
TRUMP WAS GOING TO GET IN AND
START THROWING BOMBS ALL OVER
THE PLACE.
>> NOW CONVINCED HE IS DEFYING
HIS CRITICS EXPECTATIONS, AND,
HE SAID THE BIGGEST PROBLEM THAT
THE UNITED STATES HAS COME AND
BY FAR THE MOST DOMINANT MOST
DANGEROUS PROBLEM, AND AT WHAT
HE SAID TO ME THAT WE EVER HAD,
IS NORTH KOREA.
>> OWN SECRETARY OF DEFENSE
ECHOES THAT SENTIMENT JUST A FEW
HOURS AGO.
>> THE PAST DOES NOT HAVE TO
DEFINE THE FUTURE.
BUT WHILE A POSSIBLE NEW AVENUE,
WE REMAIN VIGILANT IN PURSUIT OF
WEAPONS.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP IS ALSO TAKEN
THE OPPORTUNITY TO DEFLECT BLAME
ON HIS NEMESIS.
>> WHEN IT'S MY FAULT I WILL
TELL YOU.
PRESIDENT OBAMA BY NOT GOING
ACROSS THE REDLINE IN THE SAND
THAT HE DREW, I WENT ACROSS IT
WITH THE 59 MISSILE HITS.
BUT PRESIDENT OBAMA WHEN HE
DIDN'T GO ACROSS THE REDLINE,
WHAT HE GAVE AWAY, NOBODY EVEN
KNOWS.
>> BUT ACCORDING TO
PRESIDENT TRUMP, OBAMA IS NOT
ONLY RESPONSIBLE FOR THE NUCLEAR
PROGRAM AND THE SYRIAN WAR.
>> PRESIDENT OBAMA LOST CRIMEA,
LOST CRIMEA.
>> IN HIS EYES, KIM JONG UN
DOESN'T HAVE.
>> I WANT MY PEOPLE TO DO THE
SAME.
SOMEONE WHO DEFINITELY ADMIRES
KIM'S LEADERSHIP STYLE IS
VLADIMIR PUTIN.
HE ISSUED A WARM INVITATION FOR
KIM TO VISIT RUSSIA JUST
YESTERDAY.
WHEN PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS ASKED
ABOUT HAVING A MEETING OF HIS